isn't this incredible Sean thirty years
after we first met here we are at the
Oscars together I'm trying to remember
what I was doing at the time I remember
I wasn't I was in how Pender's first
play at the Royal Court what were you
doing I was still in school now
I remember what you were doing you know
what he was doing he was in the chorus
of South Pacific it's true right by the
way I loved your speech last year when
you got this award I love George -
Michael did you I didn't make one Shawn
I wasn't here I was working and ladies
and gentlemen I would like to take this
opportunity to make that speech now I
would like to thank the Academy of
course thank you very much and I would
like to thank Woody Allen my beautiful
wife Shakira
my lovely daughter Natasha and I'd like
to spell out swifty Lazar
and I'm I'm not on this list I don't
understand what's your name my name is
Bob fun fun oh
hey it's David Puttnam he's David Pakman
I thought they'd sent you back to
England no yeah I used to look like
Ronnie Moore you know he looks like
Roger Moore with a beard he looks like
Sean Connery or the mustache
he is Sean Connery would understand you
want to know what I was doing thirty
years ago now Roger what were you doing
I was still trying to grow this beer
well you foot boom shocka shall we do
that yeah
the nominees for the best actor in a
supporting role are Alec Guinness in
Little Dorrit Kevin crine in a Fish
Called Wanda Martin Landau in cutter the
man and his dreams
River Phoenix and running on empty
Bienstock wall in marriage of the mall
and the Oscar goes to Kevin Kline in a
fish called Wonder
there's a lot of Brits here tonight
scary but I have to thank a few of them
this is astonishing ah thank you to
Michael Schamberg the producer of the
Fish Called Wanda who got me together oh
six or seven years ago with John Cleese
and he said I want to write a movie
where you get run over by a steamroller
and
eat a lot of Michael Palin's tropical
fish I said great sounds good I'm in
let's do it and and then he actually
wrote it I'd like to thank the Academy
for naming me in this group of most
distinguished actors the five nominees I
share this with you I would like to
thank John Cleese for writing this
brilliant script for his generosity for
his friendship to my fellow actors
Michael Palin Jamie Lee Curtis
- Jonathan Benson - Charlie Crichton who
at 77 proves that even with a 20 or 25
years off there's no such thing as
growing old when you when you've got a
dream he's the best thank you very much
for this and I'd like to thank my wife
Phoebe
Thanks